en este tutorial vamos a ver más de
cerca el álgebra de las rotaciones vamos
a trabajar con las funciones
trigonométricas senos y cosenos así es
que empecemos con una rotación sobre el
origen con ángulo theta la convención
usual nos dice que una rotación con un
ángulo positivo es un movimiento que va
en contra de las manecillas del reloj y
una rotación con un ángulo negativo es
un movimiento como el de las manecillas
del reloj y nos gustaría encontrar una
fórmula que nos diga a dónde se va cada
punto xy después de una rotación digamos
que x primer prime son las coordenadas
del punto xy después de la rotación
queremos encontrar fórmulas para x prima
prima en términos de x y y ceta y uno de
todos estos puntos es muy fácil que le
pasa al punto cero cero después de la
rotación
se queda en su lugar así es que x prima
es igual a 0 y que prima es igual a 0 y
qué pasa con el punto 10 pues se va al
punto equis prima y prima cuando lo
rotamos
para determinar las fórmulas para x
prima de prima en este caso dibuja una
línea perpendicular desde x prima ye
prima hasta el eje x la longitud naranja
es x prima y la longitud morada s prima
observa que el triángulo naranja morado
y verde es un triángulo rectángulo y
también observa que la longitud de la
línea verde la hipotenusa del triángulo
es 1 porque el punto 10 está a una
unidad de distancia del origen y las
longitudes no cambian con las rotaciones
también observa que la línea morada es
la línea opuesta a teta y tiene una
longitud de prima que todavía no
conocemos la proporción del lado opuesto
sobre la hipotenusa es seno de teta
entonces jeff prima sobre 1 es igual a
seno de teta
o en otras palabras de prima es igual a
cero de teta
de la misma forma la línea color naranja
es adyacente a teta y tiene longitud x
prima entonces y tomo la proporción del
lado adyacente entre hipotenusa lo que
nos queda es que x prima entre 1 es
igual a coseno de teta lo cual quiere
decir que x prima es igual a coseno de
teta y esto nos dice que el punto 10 se
va al punto coseno beteta seno beteta
cuando lo rotamos to usa el próximo
ejercicio para practicar estas ideas